[Music]
would you see gathered outside the stock
exchange are due to the greatest crash
in the history good evening today is
Black Monday the day the Dow dropped
more than 500 points today the Dow
dropped more than Dow tumbled more than
500 points sat down by bad mortgage
investments Lehman which has 25 thousand
employees will be liquidate it is
definately recessions just that one word
is enough to summon up images of graphs
depicting downward trends alarming news
headlines fear unemployment bankruptcy
and it's all true
during times of recession the stock
market Falls house prices for businesses
go bankrupt
people lose their jobs life savings are
lost pensions that people have been
putting money in since the start of
their working careers vanish nobody is
winning or are they if recessions were
so bad why would someone like Warren
Buffett who's the fourth richest man in
the world to say he hopes to see a lot
more recessions how did a company like
Groupon which started jury the peak of
the 2008 financial crisis spread to 300
markets and 35 countries within the
space of two years meanwhile other
businesses are collapsing why would
Panera bread's executive chairman and
founder say the best time to grow is in
a recession while some see recession as
a time of turmoil it looks like others
are seeing it as a golden opportunity
and if you've ever wondered why that is
or how you near you the one that's
watching this video can profit from a
recession then keep watching because I'm
about to show you how recessions have
created more millionaires than lottery
winnings have and by the end of this
video you'll know exactly how to take
advantage of the next inevitable
recession that comes our way and here's
a little tip the younger you are the
more you're going to want to pay
attention to this
the health of a country's economy is
usually measured by its GDP which stands
for gross domestic product for simply
the GDP measures the total value of all
the goods and services in a country so
every time you get a coffee or a haircut
or buy a new car all of those things
contribute to a country's GDP and
generally a growing GDP is good and the
declining GDP is bad and if a country's
GDP has been declining for six months
then it's considered a recession people
who stopped spending as much money
business profits will decline people
will lose their jobs and then they can't
repay debts etc etc recession can really
lead into a downward spiral and you're
probably wondering our Kay James I get
that but what causes a recession and
there's the thing you never really know
for sure there are so many factors and
variables that contribute to any
recession it's hard to pinpoint one
thing which leads us to the first rule
nobody can predict the market
okay if you Warren Buffett or if you
Jimmy Buffett nobody knows if this stock
is gonna go up down sideways or in
[ __ ] circles
does that make you anxious because if
you're gonna profit from recession
there's one thing you need to know do
not panic
because no matter how bad the market
looks there's one thing that people like
Warren Buffett know for sure the market
will always bounce back write that one
down because it's all fun and games when
the economy is in a boom but when the
inevitable crash happens guess what
people do they panic and they start to
sell the homes that they own decrease in
value so they sell it the stocks that
they have a decrease in value so they
sell it notice how I said when the
inevitable crash happens wyan over the
pool I thought you said you can't
predict the market James perhaps it
would have been more accurate for you to
say you can't time the market because
one thing is for sure the market will
always eventually crash so there are
your three rules remember them clearly
and don't panic
[Music]
the economy is booming people are
spending their money like crazy buying
the latest clothes gadgets whatever
their heart's desire it is consuming
time and that means credit cards are
flying out of wallets people are racking
up debt like crazy but it's all good
the economy is flourishing so what are
you doing now is the time to sharpen
your weapons rally your army because
whilst everyone is getting greedy this
is the time to prepare for disaster
remember the market will always crash
and although you might not know when how
or why it is always important that you
prepare before it happens the first step
is to stop spending like everybody else
start saving and building up your
capital avoid debt as much as possible
and build up your credit score when that
inevitable crash comes you want to be
the one with deep pockets and a healthy
credit score ready to take advantage of
those juicy low interest rates that come
with the recession there's nothing worse
than being surrounded by gold with no
tools to harvest it go love that good
because there's an economic collapse on
the way and it's time to make your
riches
[Music]
death divorce defaults it is these three
things the reigned supreme during a
recession in a society where money is
heavily relied upon for keeping the
system going the collapse of that very
object has dramatic consequences and the
bigger the crash the harder the hit in a
recession you can expect people to lose
their jobs and you can expect people who
have still kept their jobs to have their
income reduced this means that people
will be unable to pay off things like
mortgages or any other debts that
they've racked up during those sweet
times of economic boom there's a rise in
panic and in fear and everybody is
selling selling selling they're selling
their stocks they're selling their
houses they're selling assets that they
once seen grow in value
now decline nobody is even thinking
about investing their money but you've
prepared for this haven't you see behind
all that panic and fear of everybody
else in the media there is a goldmine of
opportunity
again death divorce defaults these three
things are riddled with opportunity it's
just a matter of choosing how you want
to make your profit and running with it
so what should you be doing during this
time of economic collapse that's right
invest back into the very economy that
is collapsing and whilst that might seem
silly to the people around you you know
something that they don't for the market
is always going to bounce back and
here's the best investment advice you
can get buy low sell high
let's look at real estate the more
motivated and urgently someone needs to
sell their home the more likely they are
to sell that house for cheaper and guess
what the three biggest motivations are
for people to sell their home death
divorce defaults with those three things
already on the rise during an economic
collapse real estate becomes cheaper
homeowners are becoming desperate to
sell their houses and to make matters
even worse guess what happens to the
amount of people who are willing to buy
a house there are fewer and fewer of
them I mean all through all people are
losing money they don't have the finance
to buy a house and with all these
motivated sellers along with their cheap
real estate on the rise guess who's
gonna come in and take advantage of it
all this is why the preparation was so
key because by now you should have a
good amount of capital saved up and a
healthy credit score so that banks are
more likely to trust you when you come
to them and ask to borrow money to buy
property your strategy from here can
differ you can buy the property and let
it out for a long period of time to
generate some sweet cash flowin if you
bought the property or a really low
price it wouldn't be hard for you to
start seeing returns on it others will
let it out during a recession and when
the real estate market bounces back up
as it always will you can then sell it
and get some generous returns on that
not feeling rich enough yet let's look
at the stock market just like real
estate stocks are cheaper after all
people are losing their faith in the
market nobody wants to invest
and what's one of the biggest influences
in the stock market emotions during
recession everyone is selling their
shares out of fear I mean these people
have put so much money into the stock
market they're now seeing all of those
shares decline I mean the only way for
them to even salvage a bit of that money
is to just sell if only they knew what
you knew which is that the market will
always bounce back so it is time to open
up that wallet and go bargain hunting
because in a recession
everything is on discount let's look at
the S&P 500 as an example this is an
index fund that is built up of the top
500 companies in the United States
during the 2008 financial crisis that
S&P 500 dropped 35% but if you had
invested in the S&P 500
during the 2008 crisis you would have
four times your investment because right
now the S&P 500 is at the highest it has
ever been
let's look at businesses yeah not all
businesses fail during a recession in
fact there have been many that have
thrived let's look at the 2008 financial
crisis again because it's the most
recent one that happened I've already
mentioned Groupon which grew
exponentially during that period of time
another one is Walmart and another one
is Dollar Tree
what are these businesses have in common
they're in some way related to cheaper
prices and discounts and I mean it's not
hard to see how that can come in handy
during a time of financial struggle and
just like with any business money comes
in when you solve people's problems and
a company that is offering cheaper
prices on necessities like groceries and
other services they're gonna make a ton
of money but you want to know what other
companies profited during the 2008
recession Hasbro is another example
Hasbro is a toy manufacturer for brands
like Power Rangers transformers My
Little Pony
manopoly Netflix during the peak of the
recession gained three million members
in fact many companies in the sin
industries which includes things like
tobacco and alcohol for the exception of
gambling do really well during a
recession notice the trend a lot of
these companies are selling escapism it
makes sense right the recession is hard
a lot of people are struggling the last
thing they want to do is think about
that so just turn on the Netflix the
YouTube buy a toy for your child sip a
glass of wine at night and don't think
about your worries is by copying and
investing in businesses like these that
allow you to replicate similar results
during the recession
although the entrepreneurial route is a
much riskier one and once you've made
your purchases it's time to sit back and
wait this recession out before the
economy as it always does bounces right
back up
and there you have it your a session
rich cuz the last time we had like a big
crash in the US I made so much money
that was ridiculous of course the most
important part of all of this was the
preparation stage and whilst you can't
time the market just know that the crash
is going to happen at some point now the
last recession that happened I was only
a kid it was the 2008 crash but my dad
for example was heavily into property
and real estate and I know that he
benefited a lot from investing in real
estate during that period generally the
market is always growing so the more
time you keep your investments in the
market the more profits you can see come
from that which is why I say the younger
you are the better now really a
recession can be a very difficult time
for a lot of people and whilst I'm not
jumping and enjoy for the next recession
to happen it will happen at some point
so you might as well make something from
it thank you so much for watching but
relax before you click off this video
please do give it a like if you enjoyed
it it will make my day I promise you and
if you hated it give it a dislike and
comment down below and tell me why I
appreciate all of your feedback trust me
if you comment down below I will respond
to it I promise so please do if you have
any other questions and if you made it
this far in the video you are amazing if
you want to see more entertaining
documentary-style videos on business
finance or life in general
hit the subscribe button hit the
notification bell so you know whenever I
post next check out some of my other
videos that I've done already I think
you'll like them a lot I know you guys
are probably sick of youtubers just
shouting out all these call to actions
at you all the time but I promise you it
really does mean a lot these videos take
a long long time to edit so your support
and your feedback whether good or bad is
really really appreciated but with all
that being said thanks again for
watching I hope you have a wonderful
rest of the day so
[Music]